bientôt nous faisons se trouve sur
flandre où vous avez été très nombreux à
vous conseiller ce jeu suite à la vidéo
clip a effectué je vous comprends vous
avez envie qu'on décide ensemble vous
avez envie qu'on crée des oeuvres d'art
ensemble alors on y va j'ai recruté des
dessinateurs talentueux je suis chaud
owni vink lots on va commencer par
dessiner notre très cher président
françois hollande je sens que ça va être
très dur alors alors alors comment
commence il faut faire déjà ce contour
de tête
voilà alors onirique et présent honni
link et qui au hilton saliès atteint
déjà très doux et sept hommes ont ils
fait les lunettes il fait mais il est
bourré de talent on y vit non non mes
droits a quand même bon alors on fait
dire que haut débit qui suit avec lui
les deux autres sur le court [ __ ] moi
je m'occupais de la bouche tarifs et où
il fait tout mais dessine aussi mal chez
moi perdent les rides les rideaux et
line publie les rides
merde je fais une connerie on a fait
françois hollande des versions black
hole a tout recommencé attendez je
recrutais de georges frêche désole qui
veut venir si je viens je vais te mettre
la honte d'accord donc ça c'est un
dessin de cette personne
ok c'est reparti je m'imprègne de ce
visage alors moi je pense je m'occupais
des cheveux je m'occupais des cheveux on
va faire les petits cheveux qui dépassa
rapatriera c'est super ce qu'on fait il
s'occupe des yeux et des lunettes top
chacun son rôle par contre si les belges
françois hollande il est pas les genres
comme ça voilà prêt chez elle elle
dessine quelqu'un qui n'a rien à voir
elle s'est dit on va décider comme
françois voilà bon je mets fin à tout ça
en fait j'ai fait le trottoir vas-y fais
nous rêver fais nous rêver à la lmp est
génial c'est bien les gars à petit
piercing à chaque oreille pause et on va
lui faire un petit trait de morve qui
dégouline comme si on avait 11 ans les
oreilles les petits yeux bleus n'oubliez
pas les enfants alors là ce travail quoi
on l'a on l'a rendue en poste il est
quand même chevaux kawai
oh oui c'est beau maintenant on va
dessiner djombo attends je vais repasser
sur ces trucs comme ça c'est la
technique du mec qui jure qu'il dessine
bien ça lui a pas plu elle s'arrêter hop
voilà ça c'est john moss à jumbo en 2016
les jeux verts et violets région vers
les enfants le d'état il faut mettre du
vert moi je m'occupe juste des couleurs
je suis [ __ ] de l'ach à qu'est ce que
c'est que ça ça c'est john baumert et
qu'un gilet de sauvetage
c'est pas mal ils ont même fait les
taches blanches à les moustaches et
wayne on a le sens du détail sa personne
les a vus ça regardez le talent voilà
qu'est ce que vous faites là à non elle
fait et vie élevé
déjà on voit la différence de style
juste au niveau de l'ebit à la heavy 4k
et là il y est les doigts les dois en
oublier les doigts voilà ça c'est ça
c'est les deux doigts ou avait
totalement une pince de crabe mais c'est
pas grave
ok j'attends des nouvelles équipes il
yal'un qui nous a rejoint ça va être
rigolo on doit dessiner
gérard depardieu bayal est qui les a
rejoint
il sait pas écrire ça va être des offres
alors déjà
déjà qu'on dessine gerra est une règle
il faut commencer par le net voilà j'ai
fait un bond et les yeux mais non mais
t'es sérieux démoli d'ici là un peu
mieux j'ai dû effacer ci faisait trop
moche look tu fais quoi
c'est quoi ce gros coton de crainte
boudinés mec à la ola à la meije pita le
détail attend les contours du grade ils
ont fait n'importe quoi voilà pommes de
terre avec qu'est ce qu'on vient de
décider c'est affreux voilà avec le
petit soleil qu'on fait quand on est
aussi en cp la différence le vrai iard
depardieu et le gérard depardieu steve
et avec un petit rouge à lèvres ce qu'on
a fait tout sens enfin moi j'ai juste
fait le soleil mais c'est sa partie
connaît l'oeuvre d'art c'est de toute
beauté à léogâne tout comme vous tous à
gaumont pathé au rex et l'or grâce à se
mettre au vert drôle mais alors comment
fonctionne du marron du marron du marron
auch est jamais aussi bien fait un coup
de chemin avec une tête de cheval on va
colorer l'intérieur en on a les crocs
dirait ou délits qui sont décédés qu'on
les a ramenés à la vie ils sont
maintenant nous sommes à oopa soir ou
tôt par soir au bout de la vous avez
toudic et vous avez tout niké ces partis
moi je m'occupe du cheval de gauche
comment je les bienfaits alors la
naissance d'un tableau en live c'est
spectaculaire la tâche blanche on
n'oublie pas s'il vous plaît messieurs
dames abc déjà tout blanc [ __ ] eau
plate oumaro comme samedi à alger coeur
olala ils sont bien faits ils sont bien
faits les cheveux les gares les cheveux
[ __ ] les gars qui nous fait des vieux
poêles de moutons voilà moi je suis le
l'assistant capillaire du dessin noir
avant de faire tous ces [ __ ] poil
en fait je repasse sur ce cas mais qui a
déjà fait je suis rarement l'escroc de
la session a pris à la peau sur les os
lui et vous pouvez vous lui faites
dessin arrêter là on notera les
transformant cadavres les pauvres offre
c'est tellement bon on va faire une
petite larme le hall à la rt c'est
triste c'est vraiment beau la
retrouvaille pape
regardez c'est pas beau il ya même un
dialogue qui s'instaure entre les deux
feux qui avait un couteau bout c'est
quoi on va lui faire un bras aurait
finalement sa part en combat y en a un
que j'ai pris un coup de couteau l'autre
qui tire avec un gun sur l'autre papa tu
es
dg attendait un appel oui oui vous
l'estimez 1 millions d'euros ce tableau
d'accord merci
sescoi au gcs doit faire on va faire on
commence déjà par faire mais non mais
non c'est non on voulait mal orientés
les gammes les mal orienté hop le haut
du bébé atteint j'ai foiré dg fois rêvé
pour faire puisque nos plastique quoi
mais qu'est ce qu'il fait sur le terrain
bof déjà on va refaire le tt c'est
parfait alors la haye ont fait des
petites et et qu'il a fait de la cire
humaine l'a arrêté quinze oeuvres d'art
qui fait quoi lui a oui la joue t décide
bien des all in pour de vrai à l'ufo
dessert maintenant franchement quand on
met les deux côte à côte
ça ressemble énormément mais pour de
vrai alors là on va tenter si c'est le
truc le plus dur du monde
ok le gros challenge on doit faire ceci
c'est impossible je sais même pas par où
commencer pour faire ce [ __ ] de dessin
déjà et c'est acronis il fonctionne la
merde alors là mon cas on a intérêt à
tout donner les gars pour le mondial et
un oignon mais c'est pas grave
oh là là là là les gars je sais pas si
vous voyez ce qu'on est en train de
fermer là autant vous dire que marvel va
nous contacter dans très peu de temps
c'est fort je trouve qu'on s'en sort
vraiment bien moi je m'occupe des
détails tout ce qui est lettré la 2d
bras je les fais ta on est tellement
concentré on donne tout aulas il a des
kilos un peu la nôtre iron man et passez
moi ce graal atteint là on a un bon truc
hein pour de vrai là on a vraiment un
bon truc à ils ont fait une fumée
derrière tellement belle
attends on va faire une aura de
puissance on va faire une loi de
puissance jeu comme s'ils éliminaient
d'arrivée avec la vitesse je suis ouais
c'est moi qui doublait le bruit de
l'orage super saiyan iron égale ça c'est
la botte le numéro qua non mais là on
devrais je suis tout émoustillé je pense
que si robert downey junior envoyé ça il
serait fier de nous bravo les gars on
termine en mosquée avec ma gueule on va
voir comment ils vont faire cfdp ou là
ok sa part sur une oreille à dolbeau
déjà merci les gars c'est gentil qui ce
qu'ils pourront ils sont en train de me
tuer arrêter ok merci pour la barbade au
ça me fait plaisir un banni qu'elle voit
là je pense que c'est assez proche de la
de la réalité malheureusement alors il
ya un détail anodin qu'ils ont oublié
c'est que ça c'est pas blanc c'est shawn
arrêter avec les crottes décélère loges
c'est bon je t'ai pris en flagrant délit
avec un petit coeur voilà j'arrive
vraiment détruit la gueule mais matin
choeur diocésain des longs métrages
mieux c'est avant qu'un accident au aux
huttes belge sur floch grand [ __ ] vous
avez 100 fois plus de talent et
d'imagination que moi c'est effrayant
cause de vous mes tableaux vont perdre
en côte la [ __ ] ils en ont 10 centimes
au lieu de 20 ans entré dans une
prochaine vidéo sur demande pas d'être
une vidéo des sorts tous ensemble que
j'aurais pris un petit peu de ce qu'il
c'est à dire dans vingt-huit années à la
truite personnel vont regarder portez
vous bien sûr tout le monde